well five years ago in the summer of
2015
europe faced its biggest migration
crisis since world war ii
hundreds of thousands of desperate
people fleeing war and economic hardship
tried to reach the continent the largest
group of migrants making the perilous
journey came from syria where
four years of civil war had forced them
to flee
president bashar al-assad's forces had
increased their attacks on opposition's
strongholds
and the so-called islamic state was
gaining strength
but people from many other countries
including afghanistan iraq
pakistan eritrea they also left their
homelands in search of a better future
in europe
now faced with an unprecedented wave
chancellor angela merkel's government
decided to let them
in and almost a million migrants claimed
asylum here
as part of our series looking back on
that summer five years ago
we met up with two of those migrants
i fled eritrea because i could no longer
stand
the never-ending military service
[Music]
i arrived in germany in 2015.
i had to leave syrian
after two years of military service i
came home for the first time
i had only seen my daughter once at
birth and never again after that
when i got home i walked right past her
i just
when i got out of prison i couldn't stay
in syria
[Music]
not on the ground
i wanted it to happen only to me
i came to germany on may 2 2015.
at first i was in munich then i was sent
to berlin
doctors here in germany are not allowed
to work without a license
so i thought okay what can
people were nice and taught me some
german words
in 2017 my wife finally had a hearing at
the german embassy
right after that i wanted to call her to
see how it went
then i found out that she died suddenly
i didn't understand it at all i lost my
will to live
it's five thousand in 2017 i passed the
professional language exam at the
medical association of berlin
then the knowledge exam then i got my
license to practice medicine
then i got my first job as a resident in
neurology
my work is my life it's my whole life i
was just completely living
i can't say whether i want to go back to
syria
and live there or stay here forever
[Applause]
maybe going back and forth will be
possible
my hope is that my children can come to
me
after all that's what i'm fighting for
because i can't go back
and let's get more on the situation for
migrants in germany we are joined now by
katarina
she is the head of the department for
education and family at the german
institute for economic research in
berlin the institute has published
several studies
assessing migration to germany welcome
to the program and thank you so much for
joining us
in our report there we just heard about
the very different experiences
of two migrants who came to germany do
they tie in
with what you have learned from other
migrants
well the perception of migrants is very
different and therefore
in our reports we usually go on
different aspects
some of the experience which we heard
from the two
refugees who came to germany
fit what we find in particular the
well-being which is really
decreasing if children if the children
are still abroad this is something what
we find in various studies that family
reunification is a very important thing
for the well-being of refugees on the
other hand we
also find if we look on this example of
this man from syria who is a doctor
that refugees once they come to germany
have relatively high expectations
concerning their employment in germany
and what we find is that not all of
these expectations could be really mac
in particular
yeah in particular women and
and refugees with uh
mentally health problems they usually
can't met their
expectations okay so reunification
um meeting the expectations when it
comes to employment
what are the other issues that you know
migrants refugees
still encounter in the country
well we also looked on children and
adolescents as one example
so one thing what i think is very
positive
is that the children and as well
adolescents who are
at school actually have a very strong
belonging
to their school this belonging is even
stronger
than what we find for other
students in germany but on the other
hand what we also find
that they are underrepresented
underrepresented
in sport clubs or in other
extracurricular activities
activities which would help them
actually
to be better integrated into the german
society
yeah sorry apologies uh back in 2015
um we know that german chancellor angela
merkel told the country we can do this
looking back was she right
i think we saw a lot of
fields and aspects where i would say we
are on a good way
but i would say after three years and
this is what our reports are looking at
three years
after the huge uh immigration into
germany
it's we are not at the end of the
integration process
so we have uh reached a lot
but there are still areas where we still
have to do
more efforts to integrate in particular
female refugees to
to really get good education for
children and adolescents
and also for uh some other
adult refugees so i would say
um partly yes
but we shouldn't um
we we should continue with all our
efforts because it's still too early
to say well we managed it thank you so
much for joining us to share that
assessment
katarina spies head of the department
for education
and family at the german institute for
economic research
we appreciate it